l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennelle sur le projet de Loire
relatif à l'accélération des procédures
liées à la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires à proximité de
sites nucléaires existants et au
fonctionnement des installations
existantes
la parole est à Madame Marie-Noëlle
Baptiste pour une durée de 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques chers collègues vous le
savez notre groupe ne fait pas partie
des formations politiques anti-nucléaire
aucun président de la République n'a
autant lancé ou inauguré de réacteurs
électro-nucléaire que François
Mitterrand comme nous avons pu le dire
tout au long des débats si notre
objectif à terme est d'arriver à un mix
énergétique diversifié et composé à 100%
d'énergie renouvelable le retard pris
dans le développement de ces énergies la
maturité des technologies
l'électrification des usages et l'état
de notre parc électronucléaire actuel
rendent fortement probable la nécessité
d'un nouveau nucléaire de transition
ceci étant rappelé il est évident qu'une
telle décision ne peut se prendre que
dans le cadre d'une vision plus large
plus globale programmatique tant sur les
efforts de sobriété à mettre en œuvre
dans un contexte aussi de
réindustrialisation
que sur le développement de chaque type
d'énergie décarbonée seule la loi de
programmation énergie et climat nous
aurait permis de réaliser ce travail et
si vous avez fini par répondre à nos
inquiétudes madame la ministre sur la
question de son arrivée on ne peut pas
dire que votre réponse était très
rassurante et ce d'autant moins que
votre décision de maintenir ou
d'intégrer des dispositions de
programmation dans la suite des
sénateurs vous offre la possibilité de
nous priver de ce débat très attendu il
y a ainsi plus ni plancher ni plafond
sur la part du nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique il y a surtout désormais
tout au long de ce texte des objectifs
ou des outils d'évaluation assis sur un
seul scénario celui de la construction
de 14 nouveaux réacteurs nous ne pouvons
pas soutenir un texte qui présente de
cette façon la loi de programmation
énergie climat et le débat le débat
démocratique que nous devons avoir sur
ces questions
au-delà de ces questions l'objectif
affiché de votre texte et d'accélérer
les procédures très bien pourtant si le
rapport folk nous a bien appris une
chose c'est que le retards de l'EPR FL
Flamanville n'ont pas grand chose à voir
avec les délais de mise en compatibilité
du scotch c'est d'abord un problème de
capacité industrielle or il n'y a rien
ou quasiment rien désormais sur les
enjeux fondamentaux des métiers des
compétences et de la formation rien non
plus sur le parcours du combustible ou
la question des déchets alors que les
évaluations
capacitaires ne tiennent pas compte d'un
scénario à 14 réacteurs et alors que
nous n'avons pas de solution sur
l'anthroposage au-delà de 2040 les
raisons structurelles des retards ne
sont pas traités mais on fait de la
législation de chef de bureau sur une
part mineure du calendrier d'un nouveau
réacteur et au milieu de ce petit bloc
de simplification nous percevons de
grandes inquiétudes outre la dérogation
totale sans contrepartie ou compensation
à la loi littorale dont nous avons déjà
parlé je souhaite évoquer ce nouvel
article premier B a qui a deux
supplémentaires au groupe LR qui prévoit
ni plus ni moins que la suppression de
la procédure d'autorisation
d'exploitation d'un réacteurs
électronucléaires en ne conservant que
celle d'autorisation de création celle
de flammes en ville par exemple
date du 10 avril 2007 près de 18 ans
avant son entrée en exploitation
projetée et avec un nombre considérable
de modifications intervenues depuis et
que doit contrôler la SN comment peut-on
envisager de se priver d'un tel
processus et de le décider sur un
amendement proposé sans études d'impact
il faudra évidemment y revenir dans la
navette cette remise en cause de la
sûreté nucléaire a trouvé son paroxysme
avec la proposition à la hussard de
fusion entre la SN et l'irisn tombé du
ciel fort heureusement une majorité de
députés a fait le choix de surseoir à ce
projet selon vos modifications
expéditives vous avez d'ailleurs pointé
du doigt une sorte de coude rideau sur
l'article 11 bis en oubliant de préciser
qu'il était le fait de votre propre
majorité qui s'était éclairci c'est
cependant occulter le fait que le vote
de l'amendement de réécriture pas moins
de 10 députés Renaissance la moitié des
députés modem la moitié des députés
horizons présents n'ont pas suivi la vie
de la rapporteur et du gouvernement
votre majorité des donc largement
fracturé sur ce sujet à juste titre dans
le contexte de jeudi dernier vous avez
le fait le choix bienvenue de ne pas
solliciter de deuxième délibération à la
suite de cette échelle mais vos
intentions sont assumées comme en
témoigne le rejet de notre main tendue
sur l'article 9a afin que l'opportunité
d'une telle réforme soit à minima
évaluée vous avez rejeté cette
proposition de compromis ainsi ce projet
de loi préempte voire rang inutile une
future loi de programmation sur
l'énergie et le climat il n'apportera de
réelles accélération en s'attaquant aux
principales causes du retard qui sont
industriels et posent les bases de la
défiance entre les Français et le
l'industrie nucléaire avec cet article
premier BA et le maintien du cap vers la
fusion de la SN et de l'URSS non
travaillé notre groupe votera donc
contre ce projet de loi merci je vous
remercie ma chère collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Xavier Albertini pour le
groupe horizon
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques madame la
rapporteur chers collègue durant 4 jours
nous avons siégé débattu trouver même
parfois des compromis autour de ce
projet de loi relatifs à l'accélération
des procédures liées à la construction
de nouvelles installations nucléaires à
proximité des sites nucléaires existant
et au fonctionnement des installations
existantes je l'ai dit à ces tribunes
lors de la discussion générale je le
répète aujourd'hui ce texte constitue
l'une des pierres angulaires de
l'évolution de la stratégie énergétique
française le cap fixé par le président
de la République est clair celui du
législateur tout autant notre pays la
France peut être la première grande
nation à sortir des énergies fossiles et
pour cela il nous faut nous en donner
les moyens
la stratégie repose d'une part sur un
apportant effort de sobriété énergétique
le plan mise en oeuvre depuis cet
automne plan qui a été compris et suivi
à la fois par les entreprises par et
également par nos concitoyens conscient
de la gravité de la situation a permis
de réduire de 10% la consommation
énergétique cet effort constitue la
première marge de notre objectif de
réduction de 40 % de notre consommation
d'énergie horizon 2050
au-delà de ces actions portant sur la
sobriété énergétique il nous faut
impérativement réduire au maximum les
énergies fossiles celles-ci représente
plus de deux tiers de l'énergie
actuellement consommée en France les
énergies bas carbone en vocation les
remplacer le nucléaire répond à ce défi
de décarbonation et s'inscrit dans
l'histoire de notre politique
énergétique le nucléaire est par
ailleurs est par ailleurs l'un de nos
meilleurs atouts pour notre souveraineté
être ambitieux en matière de politique
de production nucléaire c'est aussi
préserver la stabilité et la place de la
France dans le concert des nations c'est
d'ailleurs en qualité de chef de fil
européen dans la construction commune de
SMS et de Mr que la France doit
s'inscrire comme le souligne notre
collègue Henri alfandary dans son
rapport rendu pour le compte de la
commission des affaires européennes le
présent projet de loi appelé aujourd'hui
au vote solennelle des députés s'inscrit
donc de manière volontariste dans cette
démarche il intègre des mesures
indispensables pour unir des conditions
juridiques financières et d'organisation
nécessaires à la relance d'une politique
française ambitieuse en matière de
nucléaire civile en programmant six
nouveaux EPR 2 et l'étude de la
construction de 8pr de additionnel
l'essentiel de ce projet de loi vise à
simplifier les démarches administratives
relatives au progénaires portés à
proximité immédiate ou concernant
directement des centrales existantes les
dispositions que nous avons examinées
votées permettront concrètement de
pouvoir gagner jusqu'à 2 ans dans la
construction d'un nouveau réacteur c'est
un gain de temps considérable mais soy
des inquiétudes telles que l'assemblée a
préféré repousser avec sagesse ce sujet
dans le temps ce qui permettra aux
député au sénateur de s'emparer à
nouveau de cette question sereinement
pour ma part au-delà de toute idéologie
exprimée parfois avec un certain excès
je plaide pour qu'une difficulté de deux
pédagogie ne puis-je jamais masquer une
problématique de fond aussi complexe
soit-elle la fusion asn-rsn est
nécessaire et j'en rappellerai la
portance notre volonté qui a été
soulignée par plusieurs amendements
d'adopter en commission visait à
renforcer les moyens de la SN et
intégrer en son sein les compétences
techniques reconnues unanimant de l'IRSN
le rapprochement de deux entités ne
devaient pas être conçues comme une
simple absorption de l'une par l'autre
mais une vraie opération fusion création
le tout sous la protection d'un statut
d'autorité administrative indépendante
le rapprochement permettait également de
fluidifier le processus de décision et
de gagner en coordination ce faisant
aucune des prérogatives de nos instances
de contrôle ne leur était retiré la
séparation des strates de la séparation
des strates de décision et d'expertise
était assurée bien plus encore le statut
des salariés de ces deux structures
étaient garanties il conviendra
toutefois de remettre cet ouvrage sur le
métier lors de la reprise et débats sur
le sujet de défendrai à nouveau cette
position avec conviction le groupe
horizon et apparenté salut l'équilibre
de ce texte auquel il a pris toute sa
part est un complément nécessaire à la
Loi sur les énergies de renouvelables
votez le 11 janvier dernier ce pack
législatif permet de mobiliser
l'ensemble des différentes sources
d'énergie bas carbone afin d'atteindre
l'objectif de neutralité que nous nous
sommes collectivement fixés le groupe
horizon apparenté votera donc ce texte
je vous remercie je vous remercie mon
cher collègue
la parole est à madame la Présidente
châtelain pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
prendre la parole aujourd'hui est
difficile
face à nous parlementaire le banc des
morts-vivants face à la représentation
nationale un gouvernement qui ne peut
plus agir autrement qu'en brutalisant
les institutions et les Français dans la
rue un gouvernement qui ne peut plus
décider un gouvernement défait un
gouvernement affaibli un gouvernement
empêché
la censure à neuf voix la majorité
relative se fissure la start-up nation
n'a pas de majorité et pourtant vous
vous obstinez verticalité absence de
concertation exemple de cette
obstination à l'exercice solitaire et
autocrate du pouvoir le 8 février
dernier le ministre de la transition
annoncé par la voix d'un communiqué de
presse le démantèlement de l'Institut de
radioproduction de sûreté nucléaire
l'IRSN un démantèlement contre tous et
même contre la vie de la Cour des
comptes qui le juge inapproprié et
inefficace un démantèlement décidé sans
analyse scientifique rigoureuse sans
discussion avec les syndicats sans
échange avec les salariés sans études
d'impact
démanteler l'URSS c'est un excès de
confiance un déni de l'accident
nucléaire le démantèlement a été
heureusement rejeté par cette assemblée
cette idée doit être définitivement
enterrée
mais voilà ce rejet empêchera pas
d'accélérer sur le nucléaire une
politique énergétique qui pose de
nombreux problèmes de sûreté et ne
résout pas les enjeux
d'approvisionnement et nos dépendances
au gouvernement autoritaires pour preuve
hier pour la septième fois depuis un an
les rues sont livrés à Dunkerque de
l'uranium enrichi
pour cette accélération le gouvernement
un allié sur lequel il peut compter
puisqu'il n'entend rien nos questions
énergétiques c'est le rassemblement
national le rassemble la zone le
rassemblement national et l'ignorant
utile de ce gouvernement son programme
énergétique irréaliste repose sur 100%
nucléaire un scénario Parion sur 10
réacteurs que ni EDF ni RTE ne pense
réalisable que le GIEC ne recommande pas
un scénario les réacteurs sont prolongés
quel que soit les risques jusqu'à 60 ans
alors même que l'ASN ne peut garantir
leur fonctionnement au-delà de 50
madame la rapporteur vous allez même
jusqu'à reprendre à votre compte
l'insulte des côtes terrorisme lancé à
notre rencontre par l'extrême droite
c'est la même qui vandalise les
plannings familiaux qui agressent les
manifestants à Besançon et part en
expédition cognitive contre des
supporters de l'équipe marocaine dans
les rues de Lyon
hier le GIEC publié la synthèse de huit
années de travail quoique nous fassions
les plus 1,5 degrés seront atteints dès
le début de l'année 2030 un sursaut nous
permettrait de limiter le réchauffement
sous les deux degrés mais si nous
continuons ainsi à nous accrocher au
mythe de la technologie miracle quand ma
fille aura 70 ans il fera plus de 4,4
degrés la planète sera invivable
et le calcul est simple pour savoir
pourquoi le nucléaire ne peut pas
répondre à la question et au défi du
réchauffement climatique le GIEC
rappelle que pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique après de 1,5
degrés il faut réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de 48 % d'ici à
2030 par rapport à 2019 2030 c'est
demain et si on reprend le calendrier de
développement du nucléaire donné par RTE
voici dans sa version optimiste nous
avons deux réacteurs en 2035 deux
réacteurs supplémentaires en 2040 et
deux réacteurs supplémentaires en 2045
soit 5 ans 10 ans et 15 ans trop tard la
seule solution est la planification de
la sobriété et le développement massif
des énergies renouvelables l'énergie que
le solaire connaît une accélération
spectaculaire partout dans le monde
partout sauf en France et pourtant le
gouvernement a fait une loi sur les
maisonnaires si faible zéro objectif
zéro moyen et dans les couloirs au sein
de l'Union européenne il continue à
freiner la définition d'objectif
ambitieux de développement des EnR afin
de pouvoir y intégrer l'hydrogène
produit par le nucléaire nous attendons
également toujours une véritable loi de
programmation énergie climat pour enfin
respecter nos engagements en termes de
climat et dans une trajectoire
socialement acceptable en 2005 Nicolas
Sarkozy fait le pari de l'EPR conclusion
12 ans de retard et dit une facture de
17 milliards d'euros supplémentaires et
pourtant le gouvernement fait le parti
de 14 EPR qui sont aujourd'hui ni
construits ni financés il relance un
secteur en faillite et inopérant face
aux conséquences du réchauffement
climatique cet été plus de 50% des
réacteurs étaient à la répare manque
d'eau le nucléaire et la deuxième
activité la plus consommatrice d'eau
douce 31% de l'eau consommée pour le
fonctionnement des centrales alors que
la bataille de l'eau a déjà commencé
vont nous non vraiment dépendre du
néergy aquavovore ou le nom vraiment
devoir choisir un jour entre refroidir
nos centrales et boire
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine monsieur Sébastien Jumel
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission
madame le rapporteur
collègue
le groupe GDR ça compose d'autres
communistes ou annoncé depuis le début
qu'ils appréhendaient ce texte
d'une manière pragmatique sans anathème
sans caricature de qui que ce soit d'une
manière équilibrée y compris pour
prendre en compte la diversité des
points de vue exprimés d'une manière
politique aussi
en se nourrissant d'abord de notre
héritage politique historique y compris
en en mesurant la profonde actualité
celle de Marcel Paul qui a eu
l'intelligence de considérer qu'un sujet
aussi stratégique devait être
soumettriste publique celle aussi de
Frédéric Joliot-Curie j'habitais dans
cette rue quand j'étais môme dans la
ville de Gonfreville-l'Orcher Frédéric
Joliot-Curie que le général de Gaulle a
nommé comme commissariat commissaire à
l'énergie atomique à la Libération c'est
avec cette approche politique et
pragmatique dès le début nous avions dit
pas de relation donc affective avec la
politique énergique simplement deux ou
trois choses en tête d'abord de se dire
que il fallait construire un mix
énergétique équilibré intelligent
respectueux et décarbonée
en intégrant comme première priorité la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
et lardent obligation qu'il y avait à
réduire les gaz à effet de serre et en
intégrant aussi une donnée scientifique
irréfragable le fait que l'énergie
n'était pas stockable ou difficilement
stockable et qui nous fallait quand on
électrifiait les usages bénéficier d'une
énergie
pilotable dans ce cadre
j'ai dit que si le nucléaire ne nous
semblait pas être la solution ou la
seule solution il n'y avait pas au
moment où nous parlons de solutions sans
nucléaire cette relation cette
conviction qu'il fallait relancer la
filière s'est appuyé sur une exigence
forte
pas de relance nucléaire possible sans
une armée de bras et de cerveau au
service de cette relance et ce qui nous
a conduit à porter des amendements pour
que les questions de formation soient
intégrées de manière anticipée pour
cette relance pas de d'attractivité
possible pour la filière sans respecter
le statut des électriciens gazés dont
nous croyons d'ailleurs qu'il devrait
être étendu aux sous-traitants du
nucléaire sous-traitance dont il
faudrait mieux encadrer l'exercice pas
de relance du nucléaire possible
fiable solide sans intégrer les
problématiques d'aménagement équilibré
du territoire sur la question de
l'artificialisation des sols dont j'ai
cru comprendre qu'elle ferait l'objet
d'un traitement par une PPL au Sénat ou
sans une péréquation fiscale permettant
une juste redistribution des richesses
fiscales produites par la filière
nucléaire à l'échelle du territoire
nous avons aussi beaucoup insisté sur le
fait que il n'y avait pas de relance
nucléaire sereine solide sans un haut
niveau de sûreté de sécurité et de
transparence j'étais d'ailleurs très
heureux que la mobilisation de tous les
bancs est permis à l'Assemblée nationale
de trancher avec raison l'absence de la
fusion à la hussarde de l'ISN et de
l'IRSN pardon qui était de nature à
jeter le trouble sur la relance que nous
envisageions il est heureux que vous
ayez renoncé à la seconde délibération
de ce point de vue là nous avons
également beaucoup insisté sur la
nécessité de faire en sorte que la
maîtrise publique la logique
d'actionnaire soit bannie de la relance
du nucléaire je veux dire que j'ai eu
quelques inquiétudes lorsque à
l'initiative de LR on nous a dit que les
réacteurs
de nouvelles générations les réacteurs
modulaires pourraient être confiés à
d'autres que à EDF nous exprimerons
évidemment une grande vigilance
là-dessus en ayant en tête quand même
les victoires enregistrées grâce aux
électriciens gaziers ces derniers mois
d'abord le refus d'Hercule le fait que
désormais plus personne ne considère que
pour relancer la filière il faut se
passer d'une entreprise intégrée ensuite
la PPL que nous avons votée contre la
vie du gouvernement pour renationaliser
EDF je vous annonce qu'à l'initiative du
groupe GDR d'ailleurs on reviendra dans
le cadre de notre niche pour faire en
sorte que cette maîtrise publique soit
gravée dans la loi voilà l'état d'esprit
qui nous a conduit à considérer que
cette loi technique au bout du compte
pouvait être appréhendé positivement par
le groupe son chèque en blanc avec un
haut niveau d'exigence avec l'ardente
obligation que vous avez de ne pas
dénaturer le texte lorsqu'il viendra
en seconde lecture au Sénat et sous ces
conditions là et avec ses garanties là
le groupe communiste dans sa large
majorité votre a favorablement en texte
qui nous est présenté je vous remercie
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Benjamin sainte-huile pour le
groupe liotte
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président commission madame
la rapporteur mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues nous sommes engagés dans une
course contre la montre face au
réchauffement climatique et nous ne
pouvons nous permettre ni retard ni
Herman dans les choix stratégiques que
nous devons conduire
le groupe liotte que je représente
aujourd'hui partage l'ambition d'un
objectif autour du mix énergétique
équilibré et décarbonée depuis le début
de notre législature nous avons eu à
traiter des ENR et nous avons largement
encouragé ce processus et aujourd'hui
nous parlons de l'accélération des
procédures autour du nucléaire je le
vais rapidement mais je redis ici que
nous regrettons de passer par le petit
bout de la lorgnette que nous
considérons que la logique UTT qu'il y
ait d'abord une loi de programmation qui
fixe le cadre pour que cela puisse être
possible dès le début de notre
responsabilité il lui fallut essayer
d'anticiper le débat public pour
qu'ensuite nous puissions travailler
sereinement du coup
c'est un petit bout de la politique
énergétique qui est posée aujourd'hui
d'autres sujets restent sans réponse la
crise énergétique et l'explosion des
prix chez les artisans dans les TPE ou
encore les collectivités marquent la
caducité des règles du marché européen
de l'énergie
il nous reste à savoir ce que vous
voulez construire pour EDF par quoi vous
envisagez remplacer la reine ou encore
quelle proposition de réforme vous
voulez porter à l'échelle du marché
européen de l'énergie dans l'attente de
ces éclairages il nous faut donc
regarder avec intérêt ce texte sur le
fond nous sommes revenus à la logique
quasi initiale et c'est pour nous une
bonne chose je veux le dire ici dans les
temps tourmentés que nous vivons ce
texte pose la question de la méthode
encore une fois
vous avez fait le choix
incompris par nous de proposer par voie
d'amendement du gouvernement après
l'étude du texte par le Sénat de la
fusion entre l'URSS et la SN
vous vous êtes pardon pour l'expression
escagacée à essayer de démontrer à quel
point c'était nécessaire absolument
indispensable pour permettre la relance
de la filière et l'accélération nous
n'avons pas à compris nous n'avons pas
compris parce que vous avez choisi
d'aller vite trop vite de passer au
dessus des discussions préalables
nécessaires vous avez donc crispé les
esprits et lorsque les esprits sont
crispés la discussion est toujours plus
difficile je le dis cette question de
méthode elle est centrale pour nous
aujourd'hui et madame la ministre vous
nous avez dit en commission puis ici en
séance que nous aurions le loisir de
mettre dans quelques temps en lumière
les perspectives énergétiques à travers
une loi de programmation
je dois vous dire que nous sommes encore
un peu dubitatif puisque si nous vous
croyons sur parole nous savons qu'ici
même dans cette hémicycle d'autres
ministres dont la première ministre ce
sont présentés à la tribune pour prendre
des engagements qui n'ont pas été tenus
il y a moins de 10 jours on nous disait
qu'il n'y aurait pas de 49-3 sur le
texte des retraites qui duraient une
majorité finalement chacun sait ce qui
s'est passé donc je vais vous faire
confiance madame la ministre est
considéré que votre parole vous engage
et nous engage collectivement mais je
dois dire à quel point cela crée chez
nous du doute et que ce doute il est
sans doute mortifère pour les relations
de travail entre un gouvernement qui
doit créer les conditions du dialogue et
de passerelle avec les parlementaires
dans une situation que nous connaissons
où vous devez construire des majorités
qui se qui se définissent évidemment
dans le cadre de la capacité à permettre
le compromis
nous avons donc porté avec d'autres et
je veux saluer la collègue baptistel et
l'ensemble des banques qui ont souhaité
refusé la perspective de fusion entre
l'IRSN et la SN parce que nous ne le
comprenions pas parce que nous
considérions que c'était un contre
message qui était envoyé à la filière au
moment où vous souhaitiez accélérer
d'autres l'ont dit avant moi le gros
pilote souhaite que l'occasion de la
deuxième lecture au Sénat ne soit pas la
possibilité pour vous de revenir sur le
vote de l'Assemblée nationale je crois
que si vous devez interroger la question
de la sûreté en France vous devez le
faire dans un calendrier respectueux des
institutions et du dialogue social
préalable dans ces conditions et parce
qu'il s'agit finalement de revenir un
texte technique le groupe accompagnera
très largement ce texte même si en
pointillés la disparition des objectifs
globaux nous laissent à penser que
peut-être dans le flou il y a un loup je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Travert
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
madame la rapporteur même le rapporteur
pour avis chers collègues collègues
après plusieurs jours en séance nous
parvenons au terme de la deuxième
lecture du texte pour l'accélération des
procédures liées à la construction de
nouvelles centrales nucléaires d'ores et
déjà je veux vous dire que le groupe
Renaissance votera favorablement pour ce
projet de loi je remercie bien
évidemment le gouvernement pour sa
capacité d'écoute et les engagements qui
ont été pris pendant la discussion et je
veux également saluer le travail de
notre rapporteur Maud Brejon pour la
pédagogie dont elle a fait preuve durant
des heures pour conduire ce texte et ici
l'améliorer
cela fait mes chers collègues des années
que la filière nucléaire en proie au
doute attend des pouvoirs publics de
construire un chemin nouveau pour le
développement et la confiance de toute
une filière composée d'hommes et de
femmes techniciens et ingénieur à qui je
veux ce soir une nouvelle fois et au nom
du groupe Renaissance témoigné de notre
soutien et de notre confiance la filière
nucléaire est une filière d'excellence
qui depuis de nombreuses années a connu
la défiance politique a été déconsidérée
créant ainsi un déficit d'image un
déficit des recrutements un déficit de
monter en compétences un déficit de
transmission des savoirs ces
atermoiements nous coûteront cher car
depuis la fin des années 90 jusqu'en
2007 aucune centrale ne sera construite
départ en retraite ou vers d'autres
filières le savoir-faire s'est perdu et
c'est dans ces conditions de faiblesse
de la filière que débutera la
construction de l'EPR de Flamanville
tête de série et qui a force de retard
ne sera achevée définitivement que 2024
le discours de Belfort je le rappelle du
président de la République a réaffirmé
cette ambition de faire de la France le
premier grand pays à sortir des énergies
fossiles avec la construction de six
nouveaux réacteurs le nucléaire énergie
décarbonée est un atout pour la France
nous avons été nombreux à saluer cet
engagement politique fort du président
de la République pour l'émergence d'une
filière modernisée et qui contribue à
l'image du savoir-faire français alors
que la guerre en Ukraine a provoqué la
flambée des prix du mégawatt-heure et
1000 euros sous tension eDF n'a jamais
aussi peu produit en 2022 du fait des
arrêts pour maintenance et plus
récemment de problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte près de la moitié des 56
réacteurs ont été immobilisés à un
moment où nous avions besoin de
production d'électricité et grâce à
l'énergie nucléaire il convient de
rappeler que la France a longtemps
disposé d'un des prix les plus bas de
l'électricité et qui plus est décarbonée
la relance de notre filière est
indispensable pour garantir la
souveraineté thématique dont nous avons
besoin et c'est pourquoi nous devons à
travers ce texte moderniser sérieusement
le parc français et permettre ainsi
l'électrification des usages et
décarbonés notre mix énergétique
aujourd'hui la construction d'une
centrale vous le savez est soumise à de
nombreuses formalités nous avons permis
par le dialogue sur ces différents bancs
d'accélérer la production de nouvelles
centrales en simplifiant un certain
nombre de procédures tout en
garantissant la sûreté et la sécurité
des installations et je le redis nous
l'avons répété à maintes reprises durant
le débat jamais nous ne transigerons sur
la sûreté sur la sécurité à la fois des
installations mais aussi des hommes et
des femmes qui font le quotidien de la
filière nous avons permis d'anticiper le
démarrage des travaux qui ne revêt aucun
caractère sensible nous avons créé des
procédures spécifiques permettant de
qualifier les projets de réacteur
nucléaire de projets d'intérêt général
par décret et de mettre les documents
d'urbanisme en compatibilité avec le
projet nous avons supprimé enfin le PLA
environ de 50% dans le mix électrique et
la limite de capacités installées en
clair mettons des plafonds sur les
énergies fossiles et pas sur les
énergies des carbonées nous avons permis
aussi de sécuriser juridiquement le
développement de réacteurs en bord de
mer en inscrivant dans le droit une
dérogation à la loi littorale pour les
installations nucléaires de base je veux
aussi souligner l'écoute du gouvernement
mais aussi le travail des parlementaires
pour retravailler dans un temps futur
avec les avec les parlementaires et avec
l'Office Parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et techniques la réflexion
liée à un éventuel structuration de
l'IRSN et de la SN avec ce texte nous ne
pourrons plus faire fi des enjeux
climatiques et des enjeux de
l'indépendance énergétique qui nous font
face et de la nécessité de reconstruire
notre souveraineté énergétique je sais
les désaccords qui nous ont opposés et
notamment avec les écologistes dont
l'histoire politique s'est construite
sur la lutte anti-nucléaire je respecte
ces désaccords pour autant notre débat
de fond mérite exigences absence
d'approximation et je condamne celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas hésité à convoquer
les peurs les chemins de la déraison la
négation des choix scientifiques pour
déconsidérer la filière et les
territoires madame la ministre alors que
nous ouvrons aujourd'hui une nouvelle
page de la filière qui garantira sur nos
territoires une exigence de sûreté et de
sécurité et de transparence des
installations c'est ce que nous devons à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens nous
sommes mobilisés pour faire avancer
ensemble cette belle filière merci de
votre attention je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas dragon pour le rassemblement
national
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il fut un temps où les
Français pouvaient contient compter sur
un service public de l'énergie qui leur
garantissait sécurité
d'approvisionnement et maintient de
l'activité économique quel que soit les
caprices de la météo ce temps n'est pas
si lointain mais il est désormais révolu
parmi les nombreux signes de notre
déclassement les risques de coupure
électrique de cet hiver ont révélé les
faiblesses du secteur énergétique
français c'est le résultat de politique
ultralibéral et européenne qui ont cassé
le service public de l'énergie
déstabiliser nos entreprises comme EDF
et créer un marché européen de l'énergie
ou la France achète au prix fort un
kilowattheure d'électricité quel produit
pourtant à bas coût marcher européen
dont le gouvernement refuse obstinément
de sortir défiant toute logique
la responsabilité de ce sur ces banques
qui ont gouverné qui gouvernent encore
et lourdes si ce projet de loi va dans
le bon sens comment oublier que c'est la
même majorité qui a gravement mis à mal
la filière nucléaire oui chers collègues
de la majorité vous avez fait un tort
considérable à notre secteur énergétique
en fermant la centrale de Fessenheim et
en réduisant la part du nucléaire à 50%
de dans le mix énergétique le résultat
est grave jamais la production nucléaire
n'a été aussi faible et nous risquons un
nouveau creux nucléaire entre la mise en
service de Flamanville et la
construction d'un prochain réacteur dont
nous ignorons toujours la date pourtant
vous ne proposez qu’un projet sans réel
vision à long terme et sans action
concrète à court terme avec le plan
Marie Curie défendu par Marine Le Pen
nos propositions étaient autrement plus
ambitieuses et adaptées à la gravité de
la situation compte tenu de
l'augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie
cette situation déplorable et aussi le
triste bilan de ceux qui n'ont cessé de
dénigrer le nucléaire la gauche est en
effet la grande responsable de ce fiasco
à l'exception notable de nos collègues
communistes qui quel que soit nos
désaccords ça vaut moins ce que sont une
usine et un ouvrier nous avons vu feu la
gauche pluriel désormais baptisé la
nupes faire la démonstration de son
hystérie anti-nucléaire quel spectacle
avec des écologistes toujours aussi
bornés à combattre une énergie portant
décarbonée toujours aussi prend à
défendre vos éoliennes qui défigurent
notre pays et qui ne compense en rien la
production d'énergie via le nucléaire et
que l'on rejoint dans leur combat par
elle et fille l'ancienneté en moins et
les outrances en plus et par un groupe
socialiste pas le représentant d'un
Expertis de gouvernement tellement
soumis aux insoumis qu'ils ont renié
l'héritage de François Mitterrand il
faut dire que le second président
socialiste Monsieur Hollande empêtré par
ses accords de gouvernement et cédé au
lobby gaucho écolo à accélérer la
destruction d'une industrie de 220 000
emplois c'était déjà par votre faute que
le programme superhénix avait été
abandonné en 1998 alors qu'il offrait
des perspectives encourageantes en
matière de réduction des déchets peut
vous importe à la nupette que nos
compatriotes nos services publics et nos
entreprises regardent maintenant avec
appréhension la météo pour espérer
continuer à s'éclairer se chauffer ou
exercer leur activité le sort de
millions de Français vous préoccupe peu
tant que vous êtes fidèle à votre
idéologie le progrès technique
la rationalité ou les grands
enseignements de la science ne sont pas
au cœur de votre logiciel avec vous
c'est plus Greta que Marie Curie encore
que blasphème mademoiselle Thunberg
reconnaît désormais les vertus du
nucléaire pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et même le GIEC
que vous aimez tant cité à affirmer des
2018 que la tenue de l'objectif de
maximum 1,5 degrés de réchauffement
climatique nécessité une amplification
notable de l'énergie d'origine nucléaire
de 100 à 500% d'ici 2050 dans ce
contexte le groupe rassemblement
national votera ce projet de loi qui
bien insuffisant par ses moyens et son
ambition rejoint les propositions de
notre plan Marie Curie nous continuons
résolument à soutenir la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs la relance de filière
de formation au métier du nucléaire et
l'encouragement de la recherche et du
développement pour garantir notre
souveraineté énergétique et favorisée la
relance industrielle tentadentue de
notre pays vous l'aurez compris pour
nous les intérêts de la France et des
Français valent mieux que les lubies
d'une minorité déconnectée je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vous indique que je fais annoncer le
scrutin dans l'ensemble de l'Assemblée
nationale la parole est à Madame Anne
Stan bag terreau noir du groupe la
France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente le nucléaire
parfait exemple de l'arrogance à la
française pas étonnant qu'Emmanuel
Macron en face un nouveau combat en
terme d'arrogance ici connaît cette
relance c'est le fait du prince Jupiter
c'est il décide trace sa route en mode
bulldozer c'est comme pour les retraites
finalement c'est sa réforme sa promesse
au grand patron c'est son projet alors
qu'importe 80% de la population
qu'importe les parlementaires qu'importe
ce qu'il reste de notre démocratie face
à sa volonté toute puissante même chose
donc derrière ce projet de relance du
nucléaire le prince veut laisser sa
trace dans l'histoire il veut son plan
Messmer à lui et face à cette vision que
valent le débat public que valent les
avalanches de corrosion sous contrainte
que valent les risques les menaces du
dérèglement climatique que valent les
tonnes de déchets qui s'entassent pour
des millénaires et qu'on ne sait pas
traiter
car c'est finalement le plus troublant
dans ce texte rien n'est anticipé prévu
enfonce combien ça va coûter tout ça
vous voulez prolonger encore et toujours
la durée de vie de nos centrales
vieillissantes alors qu'aujourd'hui les
fissures dues à la corrosion sous
contrainte se multiplient il y a
quelques jours on découvrait à Paris un
tuyau ne tenant plus qu'à 4 mm
d'épaisseur la Cour des comptes estimait
le coût du grand carénage la rénovation
des centrales à 100 milliards à horizon
2030 mais on en est où maintenant vous
l'estimez à combien aujourd'hui vous
vous lancez tête baissée dans les EPR 2
en oubliant que notre seul ePER 1 n'est
toujours pas en service
Flamenville quelle fiasco 5 ans de
chantier prévu et 12 ans de retard soit
17 ans au total trois fois rien budget
initial 3,3 milliards et près de 20
milliards à l'arrivée mais le PR2 c'est
sûr c'est l'avenir on va en construire 6
non 14 pourquoi pas il manque encore des
milliers d'heures d'ingénierie combien
de temps pour que ce soit validé par la
SN combien de temps pour construire les
pièces de manière industrielle combien
ça va coûter si ces 14 Flamanville 14 x
20 280 milliards si ça c'est pas un
pognon de dingue
madame la ministre vous nous avez dit
nous construisons pour le siècle qui
vient mais justement comment
s'annonce-t-il ce siècle qui vient la
guerre est à nos portes et les risques
autour de la centrale de vaporizia ont
fait trembler le monde entier or les
tensions internationales risquent de
s'aggraver du fait de la raréfaction des
ressources de l'augmentation des
réfugiés climatiques et nous on se lance
dans la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs avec tout ce que ça implique
comme risque pour la population
par ailleurs nous vivons une sécheresse
hivernale sans précédent les canicules
menacent le fonctionnement des centrales
et cet été 5 d'entre elles obtenaient
des dérogations pour rejeter de l'eau
plus chaude que la norme au mépris des
effets délétères pour la biodiversité et
pour la suite les scientifiques
annoncent la multiplication des
sécheresses la baisse de débit des cours
d'eau 44 réacteurs sur 56 sont en bord
de rivière vos nouveaux réacteurs là ils
ne seront pas opérationnels avant 15 ans
en étant optimiste on va les refroidir
comment si on commence à manquer d'eau
qu'est-ce qu'on va choisir boire arroser
nos cultures ou refroidir les centrales
côté littoral on prédit une montée des
eaux à échéance rapide et la
multiplication des événements extrêmes
en 1999 déjà la digue de la centrale du
Blayais était dépassée par les vagues
provoquées par la tempête Martin et
Gravelines le Blayais pourrait avoir les
pieds dans l'eau d'ici 2050 rien ne
tient dans cette histoire vous prétendez
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique avec le nucléaire mais c'est
finalement le réchauffement climatique
qui lutte contre le nucléaire
malgré tous nos amendements vous n'avez
jamais eu un mot pour les sous-traitants
du nucléaire eux qui assurent 80% des
activités de maintenance et qui
reçoivent 80% des doses annuelles
radioactives sans amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail impossibles de
mener votre relance sans surcoût et
multiplication des problèmes techniques
dans des conditions pareilles les
salariés ne restent plus et les
savoir-faire ne se pérennisent pas
comment justifier une telle indifférence
enfin dernier caprice du Président c'est
par un simple amendement que le
gouvernement a tenté d'imposer le
démantèlement de l'IRSN et le
bouleversement de tout notre système de
surtonucléaire reconnu
internationalement on ne décide pas en
claquant des doigts une réforme
d'ampleur pour des organes aussi vitaux
dont le travail la transparence est
l'indépendance sont cruciaux pour la
sécurité de toutes et tous les syndicats
les spécialistes non cessé de nous
alerter et heureusement notre assemblée
la rejeté y compris des députés de votre
propre coalition fatigué d'être traités
en pantin par un monarque irresponsable
l'urgence est à la baisse de nos
émissions de CO2 c'est vrai mais
maintenant pas dans 15 ans or votre
relance nucléaire là c'est pour dans 15
ans au mieux en réalité c'est la
sobriété énergétique il faut viser la
vraie pas celle en col roulé c'est
investir massivement dans la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments et nous avions
voté 12 milliards supplémentaires pour
cela balayer par 49-3 s'échanger notre
mode de production alimentaire c'est
enfin le développement massif et
planifie des énergies renouvelables
parce qu'elles sont moins chères moins
dangereuses et plus rapides à mettre en
place au lieu de cela vous vous lancez
tête baissée dans ce projet rétrograde
au mépris de la sûreté de toutes et tous
au mépris des générations futures au
mépris du vivant en général vous prenez
ainsi une énorme responsabilité nous
vous la laissons
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Marley pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur après dix années de politique
anti-nucléaires des présidents Hollande
et Macron le texte que nous votons
aujourd'hui constitue enfin le
revirement tant réclamer par les députés
des républicains
c'est l'occasion et la commission
d'enquête présidée par Raphaël
schelenberger sur la perte de
souveraineté énergétique de la France
sera rendra bientôt ses conclusions
c'est l'occasion de pointer la
responsabilité de ceux qui ont mis à
l'arrêt la filière nucléaire française
c'est aussi l'occasion de rappeler que
ce trou dans la politique nucléaire de
la France la démobilisation complète de
toute une filière a eu de lourdes
conséquences très concrètes dans la vie
de nos compatriotes cet hiver d'abord à
cause de la perte de disponibilité de
notre parc nucléaire et puis dans
l'explosion des factures de nos
entreprises c'est une conséquence très
directe et très concrète de notre
affaiblissement en matière nucléaire en
effet si nous n'avions pas été rendu
dépendant des importations allemandes
nous aurions pu sortir du système de
fixation des prix du marché européen ce
que nous avons pas eu la possibilité de
faire et nos entreprises payent encore
très cher cette faute des de ce
gouvernement et de ceux qui l'ont
précédé et les Français paient très cher
encore cette faute à cause évidemment de
l'inflation
ce texte c'est donc le revirement
politique espéré mais il n'exprime pour
l'instant qu'une intention et
traduit l'habituel défaut de méthode de
votre gouvernement en laissant beaucoup
de questions en suspens
quels objectifs de production on ne le
sait pas quel besoin de consommation on
ne le sait pas ce sera se renvoyer à la
prochaine PPE vous avez mis la charrue
avant les boeufs quels
usage de l'électricité quel choix
technologique pour les futurs réacteurs
quels acteurs pour le nouveau nucléaire
nous avons toujours besoin nous
partageons cette préoccupation avec
d'autres sur nos bancs nous avons besoin
de voir le rôle d'EDF conforté comme
chef de fil du nucléaire français
quel financement pour le nouveau
nucléaire c'est une question gigantesque
à laquelle vous n'avez pas pour
l'instant apporter de réponse et puis
quelle compétences humaines à mobilisée
pour pour cette filière des amendements
adaptés à l'initiative des républicains
ont permis d'améliorer ce texte à
l'initiative aussi de notre collègue
Sébastien jumelles sur la question des
des compétences et vous amèneront à
expliciter vos choix devant le Parlement
nous regrettons cependant votre absence
d'engagement sur la relance du projet
Astrid le nucléaire de la quatrième
génération qui
alimente mérite de régler à la fois la
question de la disponibilité de la
ressource nucléaire et de la question
des déchets là-dessus manque
d'engagement de votre part sans doute la
fragilité de votre foi de jeunes
convertis explique-t-elle ce manque de
détermination sur ce sujet
mais nous revenons de tellement loin que
nous ne ratons pas ce rendez-vous et
nous voterons ce texte de relance du
nucléaire merci
la parole est à Madame Louise Morel pour
le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de
commission madame la rapporteur chers
collègues après près de 27 heures de
débats en séance publique le groupe
démocrate se réjouit de voter en faveur
de ce projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires et au fonctionnement des
installations existantes notre ligne de
conduite sur ce texte est resté la même
depuis le début de son examen
l'accélération des procédures partout où
cela est possible et sans jamais rogner
sur nos exigences en termes de
concertation et surtout en termes de
sûreté nous rappelions lors de la
discussion générale sur ce texte que le
groupe démocrate partage les deux
objectifs de sobriété et de
décarbonation de notre économie pour les
réussir le nucléaire est indispensable
il est d'autant plus dans la situation
géopolitique internationale actuelle qui
nous rappelle chaque jour un peu plus le
besoin de criant de souveraineté en
premier lieu énergétique
à ce titre comment ne pas évoquer les
dernières analyses du GIEC rendu public
hier sur le réchauffement climatique les
conclusions sont les suivantes il
confirment que pour limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degrés l'humanité
doit atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 en objectif partagé par la France
mais surtout le GIEC conclut qu'une
action climatique urgente peut assurer
un avenir vivable pour tous pour cela
les choix qui seront faits au cours des
prochaines années joueront un rôle
crucial dans la décision de notre avenir
et celui des générations futures
fort de ce constat scientifique la
volonté politique s'est exprimée de
manière cohérente depuis plusieurs
années à présent avec des ambitions
claires et sur ce sujet précis du
nucléaire le discours de Belfort du
président de la République il y a un an
à enclencher une réelle dynamique
l'ambition de construire six nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires avec l'objectif de
démarrer le premier en 2035 et le
lancement d'études pour 8pr 2
additionnels ce projet de loi vient
concrètement donner corps à cette
volonté politique s'il n'a pas pour
objet de déterminer les technologies des
futurs réacteurs ni leur lieu
d'implantation ce texte a un rôle
essentiel en ce sens qu'il agit sur la
réduction des délais de construction des
réacteurs via l'accélération des phases
administratives des projets
cela passe par la simplification de la
mise en conformité des documents locaux
d'urbanisme ou encore par des mesures de
sécurisation de l'accès aux fonciers ces
mesures concrètes présentes dans ce
texte auront des effets sur les délais
de mise en service des réacteurs et en
conséquence sur le coup des futurs
nouveaux réacteurs de notre pays notre
Assemblée a largement contribué à
l'enrichissement de ce texte notamment
avec des mesures accélérant la mise en
compatibilité des documents d'urbanisme
mais également en simplifiant la
délivrance de l'autorisation
environnementale ainsi qu'en
reconnaissant la raison d'intérêt public
majeur pour certains réacteurs nous
avons également renforcé le rôle de
notre Parlement avec la création d'une
délégation parlementaire au nucléose
civil et le renforcement du suivi
parlementaire des travaux menés par
l'ASN sur ce dernier point l'avenir de
cette autorité c'est largement invité
dans nos débats à l'occasion du projet
de rapprochement des compétences de
l'URSS au sein de la SN
le groupe démocrate n'a pas voté en
faveur de cette démarche au stade de la
Commission et cela pour deux raisons
principales sur la forme cette annonce a
surpris et n'a pas permis d'étudier dans
des conditions qui nous semblaient
adapter ce sujet et sur le fond nous
étions vigilants quand on rapprochement
des missions d'expertise et de décision
au sein d'une même entité si la
commission des affaires économiques
s'était positionnée en faveur de cette
fusion une majorité des députés en a
décidé autrement au stade de la séance
publique en inscrivant dans la loi la
séparation de deux autorités avec d'une
part les missions de recherche et
d'expertise et d'autre part celle de
contrôle et de décision nous prenons
acte de ce vote pour conclure ce texte
ne sera vraisemblablement pas l'unique
occasion de parler du développement du
nucléaire cette année puisque nous avons
à la révision de la programmation
plurielle de l'énergie qui intervient
cet été mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que c'est une un signal fort envoyé à la
filière du nucléaire en France puisqu'il
écrit notre volonté de retrouver à la
fois l'outil et la culture industrielle
nécessaire à la réussite de grands
projets nucléaire il s'agit de lancer le
chantier industriel de ce siècle pour
cela il est nécessaire d'avoir un cap
une vision une détermination claire le
groupe démocratie est engagé et votre a
bien entendu en faveur de ce projet de
loi je vous remercie je vous remercie ma
chère collègue
alors je vais mettre au bois le projet
de loi donc je vous demande de bien
vouloir regagner vos places
je vais attendre que notre dernier
oratrice puisse s'installer
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin et clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 540
exprimé 532 majorité 267 pour 402 contre
130 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés s'il vous plaît
avec le vote du projet de loi
d'accélération des procédures nucléaires
nous avançons sur le troisième pilier de
notre stratégie énergétique après le
plan sobriété et après la promulgation
du loi sur l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables c'est aussi l'adoption
d'un troisième texte énergétique en
quelques mois et ce n'est pas
anecdotique car nous sommes dans une
période charnière une période de grand
bouleversements une période de grande
transformation une période de grande
décision nous sommes collectivement
attendus par nos cours citoyens sur ces
grands défis celui de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique celui de notre
indépendance énergétique celui aussi de
la compétitivité nos entreprises et du
pouvoir d'achat des Français ce texte
sur le nucléaire comme celui sur les
énergies renouvelables démontrent que
nous sommes au rendez-vous au
rendez-vous pour reprendre en main notre
destin énergétique en faisant de la
France le premier grand grand pays
industriels à sortir de sa dépendance
aux énergies fossiles il montre que nous
sommes au rendez-vous pour donner un
signal clair à notre filière nucléaire
qui a souffert d'injonctions
contradictoires dans le passé oui nous
sommes prêts à lancer le plus grand
projet industriel de ces dernières
années oui nous sommes prêts à cette
grande aventure humaine industrielle et
de savoir-faire qui a fait la fierté de
notre pays sans rien sacrifier à la
sécurité nucléaire et avec le soutien
des Français et des Françaises ce texte
sur le nucléaire après le plan sobriété
le texte sur les énergies renouvelables
consacre la primauté de la science de la
raison et du bon sens face à l'idéologie
et aux dogmatisme car vous le savez
opposer les énergies renouvelables et le
nucléaire est climaticide alors que nous
consommons encore plus de 60 d'énergie
plus de 60% d'énergie fossile
mesdames et messieurs les députés mettre
fin à l'utilisation du gaz fossile du
pétrole du charbon voilà le combat de
notre siècle et je veux le dire
clairement je n'ai ni le nucléaire
honteux comme j'ai pu l'entendre mais ni
les énergies renouvelables honteux ni la
sobriété honteuse la seule chose que
j'ai doncuse c'est notre utilisation
massive des énergies fossiles c'est la
planète que je vais léguer à mes trois
enfants c'est le risque toujours plus
pressant de dépasser les 1 degrés 5 de
réchauffement alors que le GIEC nous
alerter une nouvelle fois hier
accélérer les énergies renouvelables
c'est être écologiste relancer notre
filière nucléaire c'est être écologiste
car comment se dire écologiste en
préférant les énergies fossiles aux
énergies des carbonées en 2030 comme en
2050 nous aurons besoin d'énergie des
carbonée je tiens de ce fait à saluer le
fait que des majorités de projets se
soient deux reprises formées au sein de
votre assemblée pour mobiliser tous les
leviers à notre disposition pour mener
ses combats ceux des énergies
renouvelables et celui du nucléaire oui
nous pouvons trouver des accords oui
nous pouvons au-delà de nos étiquettes
politiques nous retrouver sur
l'essentiel pour faire avancer notre
pays et mener le combat contre le
réchauffement climatique je salue donc
l'esprit constructif qui a animé nos
débats sur ses textes sur la plupart de
ses bancs je veux croire que cet esprit
de co-construction perdurera dans les
mois qui viennent c'est en tout cas
l'esprit qui m'animera
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
séance est suspendue pour une durée de 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]